alors j'informe l'assemblée que j'ai
pris acte du dépôt le 19 décembre 2023 à
17h d'une motion de censure en
application de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution par Madame Mathilde
Panau cyiel châelin monsieur André
chassig Boris valallot et 145 membres de
l'Assemblée nationale la première
ministre ayant engagé la responsabilité
du Gouvernement sur l'adoption en
lecture définitive du projet de loi de
finance pour
2024 donc la Conférence des Présidents
fixera le moment de l'examen de cette
motion l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion sur le rapport de la
commission mixte paritaire du projet de
loi pour améliorer l'intégration et
contrôler
l'immigration la parole est à Monsieur
Florent bouer rapporteur de la
commission mixte paritaire pour une
durée de 5
minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la
corrapporteur de la CMP pour l'assemblée
mes chers collègues il me revient de
présenter les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire dont les
travaux vous le savez se sont terminés
il y a maintenant quelques heures en
déniant la semaine dernière à notre
hémicycle le droit de débattre du projet
de loi sur l'immigration en rejetant la
possibilité d'un débat sur les parcours
d'intégration en rejetant tout débat sur
les mesures de fermeté qui vise en
particulier les 4000 personnes non
expulsables à ce jour alors même
qu'elles ont commis parfois des actes
graves contraires à nos principes notre
Assemblée a remis le sort de la
discussion entre les mains de la
commission mixte paritaire ça s'appelle
le bicamérisme et alors replacer le
texte voté du Sénat au cœur des
discussions et c'est sur cette base que
nous avons dû travailler vous le sa vous
savez depuis hier matin ce texte nous
convenait-il ce texte nous convenait-il
s'il vous plaît non et les débats de la
commission des lois ont témoigné et dès
lors la seule voix acceptable dès lors
que nous souhaitons un texte pour les
français pour notre pays la seule voix
acceptable lorsque les chambres entrent
en dialogue et celle du compromis comme
nous l'avions largement voté en
commission nous avons supprimé les
dispositions relatives à l' médical
d'État dans l'adente l'attente d'un
débat rationnel construit dans les
prochains mois nous avons abouti à un
compromis s'agissant des étudiants
étrangers nous y reviendrons des
étrangers malades des prestations
sociales non contributives ainsi que sur
les dispositions relatives au droits de
la nationalité supprimé pour l'essentiel
et corrigé pour celles qui
demeurent nous avons adopté un
dispositif d'accès au séjour pour les
étrangers en situation irrégulière
exerçant une activité dans un métier à
intention à l'issue de ce texte mes
chers collègues il y aura donc un
dispositif légal pour la première fois
sous la 5e République un dispositif
légal de régularisation dans les métiers
en tension et comme nous le souhaitions
en commission des loi et comme nous le
souhaitions dès le projet de loi initial
ces régularisations se feront en totale
autonomie entre l'employeur et le
demandeur qui formule le titre de séjour
c'est une façon pour nous de lever les
liens de subordination les liens parfois
d'esclavagisme contemporain dans
lesquels sont enfermés un certain nombre
de personnes en situation
irrégulière je veux également me réjouir
ici d'une décision historique mes chers
collègues en dépit de tous les
commentaires autour du texte qui
euh qui concerne l'interdiction de la
rétention administrative des mineurs
dans tous les centres de retenue
administrative français dans tous les
locaux de retenue administrative et
jusqu'à 18 ans c'est une décision à nul
autre pareil en Europe mes chers
collègues et c'est une décision qui pour
nous était essentielle sur l'article 13
une disposition essentielle pour
préserver pardon l'ordre public et
assurer le respect des principes de la
République nous avons souhaité
constitutionnaliser c'est le moins que
nous devions faire constitutionnaliser
l'article 13 après des ajouts du Sénat
qui fragilisit l'article dans son
ensemble et le texte final correspond là
aussi à l'écriture de la commission des
nous avons sur un sujet important qui
est celui du lien entre la délivrance de
visa l'aide publique au développement et
la coopération en matière migratoire là
aussi pu aboutir à une rédaction
beaucoup plus satisfaisante que celle
que le Sénat avait proposé je me réjouis
aussi des dispositions qui renforceront
la protection des étrangers pour mieux
lutter contre tout l'écosystème je le
disais qui entourent les personnes en
situation irrégulière ce sont les
réseaux de passeurs ce sont les les
marchands de sommeil ce sont toutes les
victimes toutes les victimeses qui
auront droit à un titre de séjour toutes
les victimes de conditions indine
d'hébergement qui déposeront plainte
comme vous le savez sur l'article 19 sur
les articles 20 21 des dispositions très
techniques pu en réalité tout à fait
essentielles ont été adopté je pense à
au rapprochement de l'OF fr des
demandeurs d'asile ce sont désormais
lorsque nous adopterons ce texte des
agents de l'OFPRA qui auprès des
demandeurs dans chacun des territoires
pourra avec que choisir la langue
établir le récit sommaire qui leur
permettront de prolonger leur demande
d'asile avec une instruction qui
respectera à la fois bien sûr leurs
droits et les douleurs qu'ils ont pu
traverser dans leur parcours de
migration et puis je voudrais terminer
mes chers collègues sur un élément
important le titre 6 qui concerne les
territoire ultramarin je voudrais
remercier mon collègue rapporteur
Olivier serva qui sur ce sujet dans le
dialogue avec avec les territoires
concernés a permis des avancées
significatives et ce texte contient des
dispositions qui sont essentielles pour
les territoires d'autr maire je vous
invite mes chers collègues après tant de
débats après tant de discussions et
parfois de désaccords je vous invite à
soutenir ce texte je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur
général la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
d'Anin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outremires
[Applaudissements]
allez un peu de silence dans l'hémicycle
on va laisser monsieur le ministre
s'exprimer vous aurez la parole
ensuite allez-y monsieur le ministre
merci madame la
présidente madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames et messieurs les
députés ce texte nous aura appris une
chose il n'y a pas d'opposition
constructive en France il n'y a que des
opposants qui se détestent entre eux
vous
avez fil
débat qui s'agite de la nup
qu'il s'agit du rassemblement
national vous avez F le débat vous avez
refusé d'accomplir votre fonction de
parlementaire qui de
[Musique]
débattre et
vousvz
vous ne rejetiez pas le texte proposé
par le gouvernement d'ailleurs vous n'en
proposiez aucun autre
alternatif vous rejetiez le débat et
envoyez le texte élaboré au Sénat
directement commission mixte
paritaire alors mesdames et messieurs
les députés de la
nup par TR fois la
gauche auquel ma famille a cru et mon
territoire a
cru par trois
fois par trois fois vous avez trahi les
aspirations du
peuple vous les avez trahis sur la
laïcité en vous in
coquinant avec le communautarisme de
Monsieur
Mélenchon vous l'avez trahi sur le
travail
en ne valorisant pas les ouvriers les
employés vous les avez trahis sur la
police en ne soutenant pas les forces de
l'ordre et vous les avez désormais
trahis sur la morale en quandant les
voies du rassemblement national et en
vous levant enapplaudissant avec
eux qu' n'y ait plus jamais qu'il n'y
ait plus jamais de mot de morale
et vous
pouvez vous pouvez m'attaquer comme vous
le souhaitez et attaquer comme vous
souhaitez la
majorité finalement onataque ce qui
compte et écoutez vos diatrib c'est
contempler les latrines de sa renommé
comme le disait
Hugo le texte que nous proposons c'est
un texte qui avait le mérite de proposer
27 articles qui permett la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
pied et je suis fier d'être le seul
ministre de l'intérieur du seul
gouvernement du seul président de la
République qui mettra dans la loi de la
République la régularisation de tous
ceux qui n'ont pas de papier qui
travaillent dans notre
pays aucun président de la République
aucun gouvernement aucune majorité même
François miteran 1981 n'a pas mis dans
la loi de la République la fin
d'hypocrisie
qui ce sera 10000 régularisation
plus dès l'année prochaine ce sera l' de
la majorité de ce
texte fou celui qui fait le délicat
lorsque pendant 50 ans tout le monde
réclame la fin des enfants dans les
centres de rétention administratif et
c'est notre majorité qui va le
faire on p pas de mot de trours sur les
plateaux de télévision concrètement on
change la vie ici on régularise et il y
aura plus d'enfants dans les centres de
rétention Bouchez vos oreilles mais ce
texte est le texte qui permet de régler
ces
problèmes alors il n'y a pas que cela il
y a aussi et nous l'assumons la fermeté
contre les délinquants étrangers qui
peut dire ici que nous devons laisser
des
criminels des personnes qui sont sur
notre sol et qui attaque et qui attaque
nos professeurs et qui attaqu nos
policiers et qui attaquent les jeunes
dans les terrasses des cafés sans réagir
la gauche c'est pas n'importe quoi c'est
le soutien au travail et c'est la
fermeté comme on l'a montré depuis très
longtemps et
clé et Monsieur casenu et pardon de vous
le dire vous n'êtes pas au rendez-vous
de la situation pour protéger les
Français mesamesurp proposé par le
gouvernement voilà plus d'un an
connaissez 27
articles à la fin de la commission mix
paritaire 26 de ces articles ont été
validés le seul article qui manque c'est
l'article 4 pour les demandur d'asile
quient travailler avant 6 mois tous les
autres ont été validés tous les autres
sont dans ce
texte la majorité est partie avec l'idée
simple il n'y aura pas d'aide médicale
dans ce texte et il n'y a pas d'aide
médicale dans ce
texte il n'y aura pas la fin
d'hébergement d'urgence dans ce texte et
il n'y aura pas la fin de l'hébergement
dans ce
texte il n'y aura pas la suppression du
titre étranger malade pour soigner les
malades du sida et il n'y aura pas la
suppression des titres du titre étranger
malade pour les malades du
sida il n'y aura pas le resserrement du
droit du sol et il n'y aura pas le
resserrement du droit du sol
[Applaudissements]
ne vous en
déplaise le travail présidé par la
première ministre par le rapporteur
général et par le président de la
commission des lois permet certes un
texte imparfait mais un texte qui mérite
d'être voté pour la protection des
Français pour la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier pour la fa
mineur dans l'écras et pour la
simplification de notre
droit alors
vous agissez désormais comme des
sophistes qui refusent tout débat
contradictoire et ne faites que des
procès et dans ce cas Napoléon disait
qu'en amour écoutez
bien s'il vous plaît on n pas eu de
débat pendant 15 jour souffrez que
pendant quelques minutes quelqu'un
d'autre que la nup puisse crier et dire
des mots dans cette
assemblée Napoléon disait qu'en amour la
seule victoire c'était la fuite pour
lesos man viireéta la f du
[Applaudissements]
débat alors Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires un de mes illustres
précess cette phrase va vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
intéressers qui sont tous écrits au
futur et ben nous écrivons les discours
au présent et c'est cette majorité c'est
celle du président de la République qui
permet de régulariser qui permet de
lutter contre les étrangers délinquants
et n vous en desplais qui permet de
prendre ses responsabilités face au
Français qu'est-ce qui fait monter les
extrémistes c'est l'absence de solution
c'est l'absence de problème et plus
aucune morale quand vous vous levez en
commun avec le rassemblement
national alors
maintenant il y a le coq de Chantecler
il y a Madame Le
Pen Madame Le Pen quand elle fait
cocorico elle pense que le soleil se
lève Madame Le Pen vos
sénateurs vos sénateurs vos sénateurs et
renes ont voté contre le texte du Sénat
voilà un
mois tous vos
sénateurs texte nétait pas assez ce
texte était pas assez dur ce texte ne
règlerait rien désormais c'est le texte
du Sénat moin 15 mesures symboliques et
vous votez pour pour qui vous nous
prenez Madame Le
Pen vous avez dit pendant des mois des
semaines et des années que vous ne
voteriez aucune mesure de régularisation
de s papier et vous allez voter
manifestement 10000 régularisations de
100 papiers par an
bravo
savez-vous Madame Le Pen que vous vez
pas la fin de l'état d'urgence pour les
terroristes ici mais que vous votez pour
l'ébergement pour les irréguliers vous
êtes au courant Madame Le Pen êtes-vous
au courant que vous donnez les cours
gratuits à tous les étrangers qui
veulent rentrer sur notre sol Madame Le
Pen êtes-vous au Courau que vous donnez
un titre de séjour à tous ceux qui
dénoncent le marchand de sommeil Madame
Le Pen est-ce que vous vous rendez
compte que vous votez pour le titre
étranger malade
pour qu'on soigne tous ceux qui sont
malades du
sida que vous
votez contre la suppression de l'aide
médicale d'État Madame Le
Pen Madame Le Pen vous êtes une mauvaise
joueuse s'il vous plaît monsieur le
ministre et tout ce que vous avez réussi
à faire dans votre vie politique c'est
manifestement des petits coups vous
n'êtes pas prêt pour le pouvoir et c'est
tant
mieux Madame Le Pen
vous êtes finalement dans la grande
lignée de l'extrême droite des années 30
et des années
40 toujours en avance toujours en avance
pour la capitulation jamais pour la
victoire et pour le
travail manifestement
oue et
mieux nous'ons pas peurb c'est vous quiz
refus permettez quelques instants que je
vous dis
vérité alors oui nous avons construit un
texte avec le
Sénat oui nous avons construit un texte
avec le Sénat et oui nous avons fait un
accord sur la base du texte du
Gouvernement complété par de nombreuses
mesures du Sénat c'est tout à fait vrai
oui oui le Sénat le le Sénat a fait des
efforts il a supprimé de nombreux
articles qu'il avait introduit et il a
modifié de nombreux autres qu'il avait
introduit également nous nous félicitons
de l'espr de responsabilité du Sénat et
je veux dire ici que s'il y a bien sûr
quelques articles nombreux et importants
qui mérite sans doute que le Conseil
constitutionnel se saisisse je trouve
réjouissant que le Président de la
République lui-même a annoncé la saisine
du Conseil constitutionnel notre juge de
paix pour notre État de
droit alors aujourd'hui dans ce texte
qui certes n'est pas parfait mais qui
permet de prendre nos
responsabilités il y a c'est vrai des
avancées considérables et des
difficultés à laquelle la majorité va
apporter un certain nombre je l'espère
de soutien qui nous permettront de
montrer aux Français que nous nous
prenons nos responsabilités et que la
politique est toujours un art difficile
quand on l'exerce avec des
responsabilités
oui aujourd'hui nous allons simplifier
le droit des étrangers 12 procédures
pour permettre aujourd'hui le
contentieux tris demain imaginez que
nous divisons par quatre ces procédures
nous irons plus vite nous pourrons très
vite dire oui ou très vite dire non mais
nous le devons à tous les étrangers qui
croient à la France que ceux qui
respectent soit accepté que ceux qui ne
la respectent pas soit reconduit
oui nous allons mettre
fin à l'action
insupportable insupportable des passeurs
des trafiquants qui utilise des femmes
et des enfants qui viennent mourir en
Méditerranée comme dans la Manche et que
vous soutenez manifestement votant pas
les dispositifs puisque nous considérons
que c pas un délit mais un crime c'est
pas 5 ans mais 20 ans de prison et quand
on veut mesure forte on doit voter ce
texte contre des marchands de mort qui
prend de l'argent liquide pour permettre
à des enfants de monter sur des canaux
de sauvetage en leur promettant la lune
qui ne trouve d'ailleurs pas
oui dans ce texte il y a des avancées
considérables pour lutter contre les
marchands de sommeil tous ces logeurs
tous ceux qui ont été Mair ici savent
qu'il y a des enfants des femmes des
vieillards des handicapés qui vivent
dans des logement privé
insalubre que personne ne
vérifie et demain istion est au
rendez-vous de ces marchands de sommeil
enfin un délit enfin une condamnation et
enfin nous donnerons comme pour ceux qui
subissent la prostitution un titre de
séjour pour ceux qui dénoncent ceux qui
l'élogent dans des conditions contraires
à la dignité humaine
oui dans ce texte il y a l'examen de
français quand on veut avoir un titre de
plusieurs années sur le sol national et
c'est normal d'avoir un examen de
français cet examen de français c'est
tous les pays autour de nous presque qui
le mettent en place et des cours
gratuits en échange et pour la première
fois pour la première fois nous
obligerons les employeurs à créé une
forme de 1 % intégration c'est pendant
les heures de travail qu'on prendra ses
cours de français c'est pas quand la
dame aura fait 1 heure et de de pour
nettoyer vos bureaux 1 heure de pour
repartir qu'on leur dira faut aller à la
préfecture à
14h et oui et oui il y a dans ce texte
fait qu'on protège au forces de l'ordre
va permettre à nos policiers à nos
gendarmes d'avoir les mêmes moyens que
les douiniers aux frontières qui va nous
permettre aujourd'hui à nos policiers à
nos gendarmes de regarder ce qui se
passe dans des véhicules quand ils
contrôlent ses frontières qui vont nous
permettre de décliner les normes
avancées européennes que le
rassemblement national refuse d'ailleurs
l'asile à la frontière l'enregistrement
des étrangers à la frontière et
aujourd'hui au niveau européen comme au
niveau français le Rassemblement
National veut des problèmes et pas de
solution parce que ce qu'il veut
mesdames et messieurs les députés c'est
plus de problème pour plus de voix alors
que no solutions que nous apportons nous
répondons au français à leurs
contraintes à leurs difficultés et à
leurs
[Applaudissements]
demandes ce texte n'est pas
parfait ce texte est cependant dans la
responsabilité que doivent avoir les
femmes et les hommes de bonne volonté
qui répondent à l'appel du peuple il est
la conséquence de la majorité relative
et je veux le dire ici les débats ont
été longs les insultes ont été
nombreuses les anathèmes ont été
extrêmement innombrables mais nous
n'avons jamais utilisé le 493 nous avons
toujours été ouvert au débat et c'est
vous qui l'avez
[Applaudissements]
refusé la vérité mesdames et messieurs
les députés c'est qu'il y a des moments
où on se dit que oui la politique n'est
pas une fonction
facile lorsque les Français se déplacent
un dimanche pour voter pour vous ils
attendent de chacune et de chacun
d'entre nous de prendre les
responsabilités je suis élu comme
vous et dans ces circonstances
particulières nous voulons ici le dire
ce n'est pas nous qui désarmerons les
policiers et les
gendarmes ce n'est pas nous qui
refuserons les régularisations des
personnes qui travaillent ce n'est pas
nous qui refuserons les 100 millions EUR
prévu pour l'intégration pour permettre
à nos étrangers de
s'intégrer et nous nous considérons ici
et maintenant que notre responsabilité
c'est de permettre de donner au
ministère du logement au ministère de
l'Intérieur au ministère de la Santé les
moyens avec le ministère du Travail de
progresser pour les étrangers qui
veulent aujourd'hui s'adapter et pour
expulser ceux qui ne respectent pas les
règles alors ce bon sens qui consiste à
dire régularisons le serveur du
restaurant
régularis l' cuis régularis l'aide de
l'agriculture c'est tellement vra
d'ailleurs qu'il avait un amendement du
groupe rassemblement national pour
régulariser les S PAP l'agriculture dans
les circonscriptions du rassemblement
national vous irez voir les comprendus
du débat il faut savoir j'ai compris
j'ai compris que vous n'z pas lu le
texte j'avis pas compris que pas lu vos
amendements j'en suis
désolé
aujour'hui
ilutreonsabit prenons et je veux vous le
dire en aucune en aucune
façon nous allons aller bien sûr au vote
en rejetant la motion de rejet de la
France insoumise sauf si bien sûr de
nouvelles alliances de circonstances se
répétai mais je crois qu'elles ont déjà
été assez
mortifire mais nous nous le disons ici
fièrement ce texte sera voté sans les
voix du rassemblement
national ce texte sera décompté sans les
voix du rassemblement national
et contrairement à vous nous le disons
ici et contrairement à vous nous le
disons devant les Français et oui il n'y
aura pas de texte s'il n'y a pas de
majorité sans le rassemblement national
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
nupes ça s'appelle le sens de
l'honneur merci beaucoup monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
ministre
je vous remercie s'il vous plaît j'ai
reçu de Madame Mathilde Pan et des
membres du groupe la France
insoumise une motion de rejet préalable
déposée en application de l'article 91
alé 5 du
règlement la parole est à Madame
Mathilde Panau pour une durée de 10
minutes
[Applaudissements]
présidente ministre
collègues certains votes font figure de
point de bascule en se heurtant à
l'histoire longue de notre pays le vote
de cette loi immigration est l'un
d'entre eux ce texte défigurit la
France ce
soir la question posée à chacune de nos
consciences est la suivante
souhaitons-nous oui ou non faire échec à
une loi directement inspirée du
programme de Jean-Marie Le Pen
préférence nationale dans les
prestations sociales déchéan de
nationalité remise en cause du droit du
sol ce soir il s'agit de rappeler que la
France n'est ni une langue ni une
religion ni une couleur de peau mais
l'appartenance commune à la devise
républicaine liberté égalité
fraternité que le droit du sol depuis sa
création en 1515 est un élément
fondamental de notre histoire longue
comme peuple de France les personnes qui
naissent sur notre territoire si elles
ont vécu 5 ans ont le droit de devenir
Français collègu macronistes rendez-vous
à l'évidence vos lignes rouges ont été
franchies à l'heure où la fin disloque
notre pays où la vie chè plonge des
millions de personnes dans la pauvreté
et dans la solitude à l'heure où le
nombre d'enfants qui dorment à la rue
explosent le peuple français n tiendra
aucun droit avec ce texte aucun droit
gagner mais en revanche des attaques
sans précédent contre tous les droits
contre le droit de se soigner avec la
remise en cause de l'aide médical d'État
parce que les épidémies et les maladies
ne demandent pas leurs papiers aux
individus avant de faire leur œuvre 3500
médecins annonce qu'ils désobéiront si
l'aide médicale d'État était
supprimée contre le droit de se loger
avec la préférence nationale pour les
aides au logement et la suppression de
l'inconditionnalité de l'hébergement
d'urgence si ce texte venait à être
adopté il faudrait ainsi présenter ses
papiers pour être mis à l'abri par le
115 contre le droit des enfants consacré
par la Convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant par la fin de
l'universalité des allocations
familiales contre le droit de vivre en
famille avec la restriction du
regroupement familial contre le droit à
la vie digne contre le droit à une
justice équitable quant à la caution
pour les étudiants étrangers elle
marginalise notre pays la France ser
rabourgriré à refusé la richesse du
partage des connaissances la formation à
des étudiants venus d'autres nations à
grandir ainsi la vie des idées les
connaissances techniques et la création
culturelle dans le monde entier la
recherche et l'enseignement
universitaire ont une portée universelle
celle du savoir de l'intelligence
commune mise au service notre PS et de
l'humanité les étudiants qui viennent en
France étudier lui apportent beaucoup et
reçoiv aussi d'elle c'est une expression
concrète de la fraternité humaine 18
présidents d'université vous appellent à
rejeter cette
mesure la grandeur de la France
républicaine nous convoque en ce jour un
choix
décisif la grandeur de la France d'avoir
porté dans le monde
entier des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen en affirmant l'égalité des êtres
humains sans distinction d'origine
d'appartenance ni de croyance la
grandeur de la France c'est d'avoir
ainsi formulé dans l'une de ses
premières constitutions le principe
suivant tout étranger âgé de 21 ans
accomplli qui domicilié en France depuis
une année il vit de son travail ou
acquire une propriété ou épouse une
Française ou adopte un enfant ou nourrit
un vieillard tout étranger enfin qui
sera jugé par le corps législatif avoir
bien mérité de l'humanité est admis à
l'exercice des droits de citoyens
français telle est la longue histoire de
la France qui je viens aujourd'hui à
notre rencontre
elle vient du fait des circonstances
politiques qui ont donné naissance à ce
texte mais elle vient à nous surtout en
interpellant nos consciences collègues
certains votes font figure de point de
bascule René Char nous écrivait
disait-il en cours de
chute l'examen de ce
texte nous plonge dans un vertige comme
seule l'histoire peut nous en faire
éprouver la France a déjà refusé par
trois fois au rassemblement national de
gouverner le pays collègue macroniste
nous sommes vos
opposants mais ce soir il y a plus que
cela ce qui est en jeu c'est la
République et c'est la France
[Applaudissements]
collègues les
républicains où est l'héritage du
général de Gaulle Jacques Chirac a-t-il
battu Jean-Marie Le Pen pour que vous
repreniez son programme 20 ans après
allez-vous acter la disparition de la
droite
républicaine la France se construit par
l'unité de son peuple et l'attachement
au principes de la République en ce jour
nous ne devons pas penser à notre
appartenance partisane
nous sommes devant ce vote appelés à
défendre l'identité républicaine de la
France nous sommes devant ce vote
appeler à nos consciences de citoyens de
députés ayant l'honneur de représenter
le peuple et d'être l'expression de sa
souveraineté la rationalité humaine est
au cœur de la discussion républicaine
elle en est la base même en votre fort
intérieur par les voies où la raison se
ferait un passage qui rejoint les
convictions profondes que nous portons
en nous
vous savez que cette loi est une
violence insupportable pour les
principes que nous avons en commun car
frapper l'étranger c'est se préparer à
se frapper soi-même la dégradation des
droits pour certains prépare
immanquablement la dégradation des
droits pour tous quand elle ne
l'accompagne pas d'un même mouvement
terrible rien ne peut prévaloir sur
cette pensée nul intérêt n'est plus
grand que celui que vous devinez
clairement cette loi bfou les principes
qui unissent le peuple de la République
française il n'est pas venu le jour où
le pays s'erit à la division se
tournerit contre quiconque est différent
plongerai dans une culture de la haine
qui ne nous ressemble en rien la France
ne se reconnaît pas dans le roniment du
droit du sol la France ne se reconnaît
pas dans le tri entre étudiants
nationaux et internationaux la France ne
se reconnaît pas non plus dans la
préférence nationale une idée qui se
présente à nous comme une insulte à
notre histoire commune la France ne peut
pas se reconnaître dans ce texte pas
d'avantage que les
Français l'histoire longue vient à notre
rencontre et elle nous apprend à prendre
une décision qui soit à la hauteur de ce
que nous sommes collectivement rejeter
ce texte collègu c'est honorer notre
histoire collective nous porter à sa
hauteur
collègues certains votes font figure de
Point de Bascule
ose penser par toi-même nous en
Emmanuel ayons comme nous envit ce grand
philosophe le courage de faire usage de
notre entendement pensons à la rencontre
de l'histoire longue de notre pays
décidons éclairé par ces lumières qui si
parfois ell peuvent donner l'impression
de vaciller ne cesse pourtant d'éclairer
et notre pays et l'humanité
universelle ce
soir sachant répondre à l'appel des
principes républicains que pour les
avoir partag
de nos frontières nous devons d'abord
respecter en leur sein la République
souffre aujourd'hui de voir une telle
loi présentée devant l'hémicycle collègu
certains votes font figure de Point de
Bascule nous parlons à ce pupitre en
cours de chute mais à l'issue de ce vote
la République peut sortir grandi ravi de
s'être défendu de tomber dans un imbî de
déraison et
d'injustice la républut
grand écouez les conseils d'un grand
poète emprisonné puis exilé en France
Abdelatif Labi j'atteste qu'il n'y a
d'être humain que celui qui combat sans
relâche la haine en lui et autour de lui
celui qui dès qu'il ouvre les yeux le
matin se pose la question que vais-je
faire aujourd'hui pour ne pas perdre ma
qualité et ma fierté d'êtes
humains je vous remerci madame la
Présidente
merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur le
Ministre merci madame la présidente
madame la Présidente panneau je vous ai
bien
écouté et j ai trouvé une grande
différence avec le discours que j'ai pu
prononcer c'est que moi j'ai refusé les
voix du rassemblement
national
merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre s'il vous
plaît alors nous allons passer aux
explications de vote sur la
[Applaudissements]
motion alors s'il vous
plaît chaque groupe va pouvoir
s'exprimer et donner ses explications de
vote pour une durée de 2 minutes le
premier à s'exprimer va être le groupe
horizon par l'intermédiaire de Monsieur
Philippe
Prad merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues permettez-moi
de m'interroger sur
l'opportunité de cette motion de rejet
préalable en effet un peu de patience
d'ici 1h3 ceux qui veulent s'opposer à
ce texte auront la possibilité de le
faire à l'occasion d'un vote franc
massif s'il le souhaite mais un peu de
patience en effet après nous avoir privé
de de semaines de débat où nous aurions
pu débattre projet contre projet vous
souhaiteriez maintenant nous priver de C
malheureuse minute à la tribune pour que
chaque groupe puisse exprimer en
responsabilité la position qu'il
souhaite avoir sur ce texte sur les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire c'est pour cela que le groupe
horizon et apparenté s'opposera
fermement à cette motion de rejet
[Applaudissements]
préalable
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Présidente Chatelin pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
nous l'avons tous et tous expérimenté
comme tous ceux et toutes celles qui
nous regardent quand on est dans l'urne
on est seul avec soi-même car on sait
que son vote s'engage nous engage ous et
engage
notre notre avenir
[Applaudissements]
collectif s'il vous
plaît
alors s'il vous plaît est-ce que chaque
personne chaque orateur peut exprimer la
position de son groupe de façon à ce
qu'elle soit entendue madame la
Présidente Chatelin
allez-y merci madame la Présidente
je vous l'ai dit quand on est dans
l'urne on est seul face avec soi-même et
moi le 10 avril 2022 les écologistes
n'ont pas tremblé ils n'ont pas hésité
ils ont eu la voix ferme et ils ont
appelé très clairement à voter Emmanuel
Macron comme des millions de Français
j'ai fait prévaloir mes convictions mon
attachement à la République et j'ai voté
Emmanuel Macron et aujourd'hui je le dis
des millions de Français se sent trahis
se sentent honteux d'avoir fait ce
vote car le seul mandat qui était le
vôtre c'était de défendre nos valeurs
liberté égalité fraternité de faire un
barrage aux idées du rassemblement
national et vous pouvez vouloir décomter
les voix du rassemblement national cela
n'effacera pas le contenu de votre loi
et madames et Messieurs mes collègues
mes chers collègues si vous votez pour
vous votez pour inscrire dans la loi la
préférence nation
e vez pour les idé du rassemblement
national il n'y a pas il n'y a
[Applaudissements]
pas il n'y a pas demander impératif
votre loyauté votre loyauté vous la
devez d'abord et avant tout à votre
conscience puis votre loyauté vous le
devez à vos électeurs Emmanuel Macron
vous a peut-être convoqué dans son
bureau doit répondre à ses électeurs et
c'est extrêmement clair il n'y aura plus
de barrage républicain si vous cédez au
rassemblement national si vous salissez
la République que défendrez-vous que
défendrez-vous si vous salissez la
République nous sommes fermes sur nos
valeurs nous liberté égalité fraternité
chers collègues fa de même vez avec
votre
[Applaudissements]
confiance je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame ela
fossillon pour le groupe
GDR merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre vous ne
savez même plus qui vous devez
convaincre et je dois vous le dire c'est
assez pathétique vous insylez le venin
du désordre et de la haine nous voulons
dire évidemment que nous voulons rejeter
avec force et avec responsabilité ce
texte de la honte VE ce texte c'est
intégré en droit la préférence nationale
c'est
attenté c'est attenter au droit du sol
c'est rétablir la déchéance de
nationalité et c'est même c'est même
supprimer des droits pour des enfants
français nés sur le sol français de
parents étrangers il décline dans le
droit une idéologie mortifère qui
distingue les étrangers des nationaux
ceux qui pourraient se réclamer de la
patrie et ceux qui ne le pourra
la France ce n'est pas ça le droit du
sol comme l'hospitalité sont depuis des
siècles au fondement de notre
nation vous poussez à la désobéissance
civile mais que vous le vouliez ou non
les médecins continueront à soigner
toutes et tous les professeurs enseigné
à toutes et tous les travailleurs
sociaux à accompagn toutes et tous car
c'est ça notre
nation c'est avec gravité que nous
allons voter pour cette motion de rejet
la gravité de Cell et qui redoute que
l'irréparable soit commis la gravité de
celles et ceux qui espèrent jusqu'au
bout que le déshonneur ne s'ajoute pas à
la compromission
l'irréparable voilà le résultat de cette
folle volonté de faire passer coûte que
coûte un texte pour lequel vous n'avez
pas de majorité un texte qui dès le
début portait les germes de la honte la
honte elle est maintenant totale toutes
les lignes rouges ont été franchi vous
avez cédé à tout pour trouver un accord
avec la droite aligné sur les
propositions du rassemblement
déchéance quelle faute historique de
dresser ai un plateau d'argent à
l'extrême droite à l'heure de la fièvre
populisme et du fasciste qui gang nos
démocra l'histoire nous regarde C cette
folie je vous
remerci la parole est à monsieur le
Président Pancher
pourés notre groupe toujours été guidé
par la recherche de mesur effic et just
effic citoyens sont de plus en plus
désabusés de la politique et croient de
moins en moins à la parole publique
juste parce que les valeurs de la
République sont fondamental à nos yeux
notamment l'idéal de fraternité le
groupe lot a depuis le début rappelé
l'importance de présenter un texte
équilibré sans angélisme ni extrémisme
c'est à cela que nous avons uvré en
commission avec la régularisation des
métiers en tension le maintien de l'aide
médicale d'État l'interdiction du
placement en centre ou lieu de rétention
administrative l'intégration par la
langue aujourd'hui le texte qui nous est
soumis au vote s'éloigne dans l'esprit
et dans sa rédaction de son objectif
principal nous aurions souhaité comme
les Français un vrai débat nous en avons
été privés en séance en première lecture
le groupe lot fait le constat amer que
le projet de loi immigration est
aujourd'hui source de
grande fracturation politique les
Français sont médusés face à des
intrigues d'un autre
dans une commission mixte paritaire
opaque qui ne traduit ni la
représentativité de l'Assemblée
nationale ni la diversité des Français
c'est un échec collectif et notre
démocratie est malade nous en avons
appelé dès la publication du texte de la
CMP le gouvernement et le président de
la République à remettre en chantier dès
à présent ce texte afin de permettre de
travailler dans la sérénité à un texte
qui garantira l'unité du pays sur ce
sujet essentiel c'était le bon sens nous
avons besoin de plus de transparence de
débat de concertation en amont et de
recherche du consensus la premièe
initiale d'un texte coconstruit avec
notre groupe rassembleur n'a finalement
pas pu être tenu comme le disait
Stéphane sveg l'opinion c'est la masse
la conviction c'est l'homme c'est en
application de cette max
consetteet
Etex merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à
Madame
[Applaudissements]
préséste sur le Percho donne fond des le
de dignité et
républoupe
lamise image indigne de cette assemblée
et indigne de la
République ensuite on a entendu ici les
groupes de la nuupesse honnêtement
l'incompétence on se demande dans quelle
mesure l'incompétence ne le dispute pas
à la bêtise ce texte était de votre
point de vue trop à droite alors que
vous l'avez qu'avez-vous fait vous avez
voté une motion de rejet avec les
députés du Front national pour que ce
texte reparte au Sénat et qu'on se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans cette
situation de blocage que vous dénoncez
vous-même voilà ce que vous avez fait et
là aujourd'hui au fond vous nous
reproposez la même chose quant à vos
alli de circonstances le rassemblement
national au moment du vote du texte au
Sénat il ne votait pas le texte au Sénat
parce que le texte du Sénat comportait
un article de régularisation le fameux
article 4 B et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
les mêmes députés du rassemblement
national votent le texte parce qu'il
comporte l'article 4 b est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer au fond pourquoi
vous soutenez des articles de
régularisation donc nous sur ce texte
nous avons ce n'est pas un texte idéal
pour la majorité nous le savons nous
avons fait un texte de compromis mais
nous sommes fiers d'y avoir un texte
mesure de régularisation nous sommes
fiers d' interdire les mineurs dans les
cras nous sommes fiers de pouvoir faire
en sorte que des étrangers obtiennent un
titre de séjour en dénonçant leurs
passeurs ou leur marchand de sommeil
voilà ce dont nous sommes fiers et nous
sommes fiers aussi des mesures
d'éloignement que comporte ce texte et
qu'il permettra d'éloigner des
délinquants ou des criminels étrangers
donc évidemment nous voterons contre
cette motion de rejet merci
beaucoup je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame
pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente la
semaine dernière le groupe rassemblement
national a voté en faveur d'une motion
de rejet car le texte signé d'armanin
oulier était profondément
immigrationniste dangereux et ne
correspondait pas aux attentes des
Français ce soir la Gauche propose de
rejeter le texte de la CMP qui a presque
effacé toutes les mesures favorables à
l'immigration et qui propose quelques
avancées vis à durcir les conditions de
regroupement familial de droit du sol de
délivrance de titre de séjour bref un
texte
incontestablement inspiré par Marine Le
Pen en déposant cette motion de rejet
l'extrême gauche fait une fois de plus
la démonstration qu'elle est aveuglée
par son idéologie et qu'elle est
profondément déconnecté des
préoccupations des Français et oui
collègu de la nupes les Français sont 68
% à vouloir réformer l'aide médicale C
d'État 74 % à vouloir supprimer le droit
du sol 80 % à vouloir éétablir le délit
de séjours irrégulier et autant veulent
faire exécuter les OQTF toutes les OQTF
ah oui monsieur daranin vous aurez beau
montter à la tribune mais aussi sur vos
grands chevaux pour parler une fois
encore de celle qui visiblement vous
obsède beaucoup Marine Le Pen et vous
pourrez faire votre donneur de leçon
mais Monsieur le ministres les Français
ne se feront pas duper par votre
mascarade ils connaissent votre bilan
ils savent avec vous c'est seulement 7 %
d'exécution de qtf alors Monsieur le
Ministre un peu de modestie enfin parce
que ce texte consacre plusieurs
victoires idéologiques du rassemblement
national même s'il est imparfait mais
les Français l'amélioreront lorsque nous
leur donnerons la parole par voie de
référendum nous voterons contre la
motion de rejet de l'extrême gauche
immigrationniste je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
je s'il vous plaît je vous indique que
sur le vote de la motion de rejet
préalable je suis saisie d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe la
France insoumise le scrutin est annoncé
dans l'ENSEM de l'Assemblée nationale on
a encore un peu de temps j'ai encore
quatre orateurs madame André Tor pour le
groupe
LFI madame la Présidente l'introduction
d'un cautionnement pourro de première
carte de séjour temporaire aux étudiants
internationaux est contraire à l'idéal
d'accueil de la France qui fait
l'honneur de notre pays le
conditionnement des prestations sociales
à une durée de résidence de 5 ans
contribuera à maintenir dans la
précarité les personnes étrangères et
contr contrevient à de nombreux droits
garantis par notre pays le droit au
logement l'intérêt supérieur des enfants
à une protection sociale et un niveau de
vie
adéquate ces mots ne sont pas les
mais du président sachouer il tira de
l'exposé sommaire des amendements de
suppression qu'il a fait adopter en
commission des lois avec les rapporteurs
Renaissance et modem il y a une semaine
et aujourd'hui
revirement chers collègues vous avez été
élu par défaut pour faire barrage à
l'abject
réveillez-vous
à défendre le principe de préférence
nationale vous vous apprêtez à voter
pour l'héritage du vichisme en acceptant
le principe de déchéance de
nationalité Jean-Marie Le Pen respire
encore et croyez-moi il jubile vous
cédez aux passions les plus terribles de
l'extrême droite embusqué vous sillez la
branche sur laquelle vous êtes assise et
assis en creusant notre tombe chaque
jour un peu plus s'abstenir c'est
soutenir les députés de la France
insoumise voteront le rejet de ce texte
nous exhortons les derniers républ
républicains authentiques de cette
émicycle faire auut avant de voir notre
pays basculer dans
l'abîme je vous
remercie
la parole est à Madame Annie jeunevard
pour le groupe les
républicains
merci merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur général
chers
collègues nous rejetons votre motion
pour l'outrange de vos propos votre
marque de fabrique qui veut interdire le
débat disqualifier l'opposant provoqué
vous voulez le chaos ici comme dans la
rue le bruit et la fureur sont vos
éléments nous rejetons votre motion
parce que vous n'entendez pas 70 % des
Français y compris chez ceux de vos
électeurs qui se désolent de l'absence
d'une politique migratoire à laquelle le
texte des républicains permettra enfin
de
répondre mais surtout nous rejetons
votre motion parce que la misère humaine
que vous déplorez est le fruit du
laxisme que vous continuez aveuglément à
soutenir et à amplifier dont nous voyons
le désastre dans nos villes vous en êtes
les tristes comptables nous rejetons
votre motion parce que la France a
besoin de mesures fermes que
courageusement nous avons inscrit dans
ce texte qui porte la marque des
républicains je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la
[Applaudissements]
parole la parole est à Madame la
vice-présidente et le JAC et la forge
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate merci madame la
Présidente une nouvelle motion de rejet
encore une nouvelle fois vous ne
souhaitez pas
débattre
une nouvelle
fois avec
obstination avec
fureur avec bruit vous ne souhaitez pas
débattre je tiens à vous dire mes chers
collègues que de très nombreux
concitoyens ont été choqués très choqués
par ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière le fait que vous refusiez de
débattre moi je souhaitais qu'on puisse
débattre bre du fond qu'on puisse
évoquer ces textes et vos cris monsieur
Lucas n'y changeront rien n'y changeront
rien le bruit et la fureur ne remplac
pas la réflexion et la
raison c'est pour ça mes chers collègues
ça ne sera pas une surprise pour vous
nous ne voterons pas cette motion de
rejet
nous souhaitons le débat au groupe
démocrate je vous
remercie merci
beaucoup le dernier orateur sera
monsieur Arthur de laapte pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le ministre vous
avez dit que vous n'aviez pas besoin des
voix du rassemblement national c'est
normal vous en êtes le porte-voix chers
collègues
il y a des soirs où notre vote compte
plus que d'autres ce vote il sollicite
votre conscience ce vote il marquera
l'histoire de votre mandature mais il
marquera aussi l'histoire de la
République ce soir
collègue vous avez le choix entre un
texte que vous n'avez pas voulu que vous
n'avez pas souhaité que vous n'avez pas
écrit ce soir vous regardez l'abîme vous
regardez le gouffre au bord duquel vous
êtes et vous vous dites que vais-je
faire que vais-je faire allez-vous
collègues mettre en place des côas
migratoires comme le voulait la droite
et le rassemblement national allez-vous
durcir le regroupement familial
allez-vous restreindre l'accès à
l'hébergement d'urgence qui était
jusqu'à ce soir inconditionnel
allez-vous restreindre les arrivrêvés
d'étudiants qui viennent sur notre sol
et qui construisent et font la France de
demain allez-vous mettre place le dél
séjour irrégulier allez-vous
conditionner à 5 ans et en travail des
aides sociales qui plongeront des
personnes qui vivent en France dans la
misère ce soir vous pouvez consacrer la
victoire idéologique du rassemblement
national où vous pouvez
renoncer vous pouvez
résister vous pouvez sortir de cet
hémicycle la tête
hauteô
vous pouvez
stir serein plutôt que la mine défite
collègu regardez et lisez ce texte que
vous venez de découvrir et alors une
fois que vous aurez rejeté ce texte vous
pourrez regarder ces femmes ces hommes
ces enfants vous allez mettre dans la
misère les yeux dans les yeux vous
pourrez vous regarder dans le miroir et
vous pourrez regarder votre concitoyen
en disant oui j'ai sauvé la République
alors mes chers collègues je vais mettre
au voix cette motion de rejet préalable
et je vous demande de bien vouloir
regagner vos
places le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du
scrutin votant 541 exprimé 539 majorité
270 pour 155 contre 384 l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas
[Applaudissements]
adopté avant d'appeler le premier
orateur inscrit dans la discussion
générale je vous rappelle que pour la
lecture des conclusions des commissions
mixtes paritaires les interventions dans
la discussion générale valent
explication de vote interventions
dure 5 minutes par
groupe le premier à s'exprimer Monsieur
Philippe Pradal pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
horizon merci à ceux qui quittent
l'hémicycle de le faire dans le calme
pour respecter
[Musique]
l'orateur merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madamees et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous y
sommes
enfin les Français aujourd'hui sont
lassés lassés mais plus encore ils sont
animés par un profond sentiment
d'injustice voire parfois d'abandon en
matière de logement ou d'accès aux soins
pour ne prendre que ces deux exemples et
ce sentiment est factuellement ce sont
les sondages qui nous le disent conjugué
avec les difficultés né d'une
immigration qui n'est pas
choisie de cette séquence ce qu'ont
retenu les Français c'est que le
gouvernement proposait un texte
ambitieux qui reposait sur deux piliers
essentiels fermeté et
intégration ce qu'ont retenu les
Français c'est que ce texte a été adopté
une large majorité au Sénat intégrant
les mesures plus dures mais qui
s'inscrivait globalement et comme nous
l'avons dit à de nombreuses reprises
dans une direction souhaitée
ce qu'ont retenu les Français c'est que
cet hémicycle a été privé d'un débat qui
s'il fallait le rappeler est la raison
d'être de notre mandat et ce à la suite
d'une alliance des contraires ce qu'ont
retenu les Français enfin c'est qu'une
voix exister pour enfin voter un texte
important ce qu'ont retenu les Français
c'est que madame la Première ministre
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des autres mires et l'ensemble du
gouvernement un pe silence s'il vous
plaît
mais respect l'orateur on est tous des
parlementaires dans cet hémicycle la
moindre des choses c'est de
[Applaudissements]
s'écouter les Français comme je disais
c'est les efforts de madame la Première
ministre monsieur ministre de
l'Intérieur et desr et l'ensemble du
gouvernement avec la majorité pour pas
venir à un accord je vous dis avec
lucidité sans crainte ce soir tous les
regards sont tournés vers notre
assemblée nous devons être à la hauteur
nous devons agir en responsabilité et ne
pas priver les Français d'un texte
qu'ils attendent face au vertiges
démographiqu auquel nous sommes déjà
confrontés face à une politique
migratoire qui a trop souvent conduit à
des largesse et des permissivités face à
la forte tension que notre modèle social
subit les Français attendent que la
politique renoue avec l'action efficace
de l'État et retrouve sa puissance et la
maîtrise des flux sur le territoire il
faut agir et ce projet de loi est une
pierre indispensable à l'édifice de
cette réconciliation parce qu'il donne
les moyens à l'administration et à la
justice de faire les choix nécessaires à
la préservation de notre cohésion
sociale lorsque le pacte social est
rompu il nous faut s'armer des moyens
juridiques adéquats pour expulser et
pour ouvrir la possibilité de lever
certaines protections cela apparaît
comme une évidence pour nombre d'entre
nous mais personne n'avait eu le courage
de le faire jusqu'à présent
un étranger qui briserait le contrat
social qu'il a passé avec la France en
commettant un délit grave doit être
éloigné du territoire et la durée de sa
présence sur le territoire ne serurait
justifieré à elle seule son maintien sur
notre sol ce texte est indispensable
aussi car il replace les valeurs de la
République ainsi que la langue et le
travail au cœur de l'intégration cette
exigence républicaine ce n'est pas même
une condition c'est unéalable
l'immigration ne saurait conduire à un
délitement de nos valeurs non elle
pourit conduire à s'éloigner de l'idée
que nousous faisons de la France du
respect de la défense de nos valeurs
fondamentales cell qui structure notre
pays les valeur de la République le
travail ensuite c'est une condition
incontournable de l'intégration et de la
nécessaire contribution de chacun à la
société française finalement envoyer un
message clair sans travail ni adhésion
aux valeurs de la République
l'intégration ne peut avoir lieu
retrouver un état puissant c'est aussi
assumer de dire que ce texte est
insuffisant car pour reprendre le
contrôle et maîtriser l'immigration nous
avons besoin de l'Union européenne la
France n'est pas une île et même quand
on est une île comme la Grande-Bretagne
cela n'est pas si facile mais faire
croire qu'une politique isolée et
individuelle de la France au sein d'un
espace de libre circulation des
personnes est possible c'est un mensonge
pur et simple c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous croyons profondément qu'il
est absolument nécessaire que les
négociations sur le pacte asile
immigration au niveau européen
aboutissent conscient des insuffisances
révélées par le Règlement Dublin vous
l'aurez compris sur ce chemin sinueux
tâchons d'être à la hauteur et de ne pas
jouer avec les fractures de notre pays
il en va de notre responsabilité
individuel et collective le groupe
Horizon est apparenté votera ce texte
car nous sommes responsables et
conscients de nos devoirs de députés qui
sommes là pour faire la loi de
représentants de nos électeurs qui nous
demandent un texte et à l'égard de la
France que nous devons armer pour faire
face au défis de notre temps une
civilisation repose sur ce qui est exigé
des hommes non sur ce qu'il leurit
fourni
saexupér je vous
remercie la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Benjamin Lucas pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste monsieur
non
mais madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues je regarde cet
hémicycle et j'ai peut-être pour la
première fois depuis le début de mon
mandat le sentiment que nous n'y sommes
pas
seuls le sentiment que nous sommes
ici accompagné d'un héritage qui nous
dépasse d'une histoire celle de la
République qui nous
oblige mes chers collègues un texte qui
traite des étrangers votter avec
l'extrême droite par l'extrême droite et
pour l'extrême droite jamais je n'aurais
cru que ce soit possible dans l'émicycle
de l'Assemblée
[Applaudissements]
nationale deà les oppositions légitimes
nécessaires qui font vivre la démocratie
un héritage que nous avons en partage un
serment que nous avons en partage celui
de préserver la République celui de
préserver l'âme de la République celui
de préserver l'identité de la République
et de ses valeurs liberté égalité
fraternité or mes chers
collègues vous avez monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur parlé tout à l'heure de
trahison supposée de la gauche vous vous
avez trahi cette histoire trahi ces
valeurs et en somm à l'instant dans
lequel nous sommes trahi la République
en trahissant les millions de Françaises
et de Français qui ont choisi à deux
reprises d'élire et de réélire Emmanuel
Macron uniquement pour être le gardien
de ces valeurs
républicaines vous avez offert à
l'extrême droite je cite ces mots une
victoire idéologique majeure vous avez
cédé surtout et vous avez surtout
cédé restreignant le regroupement
familial faisant revenir la préférence
nationale pour les prestations social
dans le droit
français mettant fin à l'automaticité du
droit du
sol faisant la déchéance de nationalité
facilitant les expulsions et les mesures
d'éloignement restaurant sé jour
irrégulier promettant la réforme de
laame en 2024 et
restreignant construisant des
restrictions et des discriminations pour
les étudiants étrangers qui sont
pourtant une source de rayonnement et
d'influence pour notre pays à travers le
monde pour la première fois de
l'histoire de la 5e République vous avez
touché au droit du sol c'est un crime
indélébile sur notre devise
républicaine alors oui nous assumons des
convictions une boussole républicaine
l'amour des nôtres venus d'ailleurs et
qui vont vivre dans leur chair le choix
d'une politique guidée par des intérêts
politiciens par l'obsession du forcenet
de l'Élysée qui veut décider de tout
seul qui voulait un texte à n'importe
quel prix et qui a fini en notaire de LR
la droite radicalisé au Sénat à eux je
veux dire que nous ne baisserons ni la
tête ni les bras depuis cet après-midi
et c'est là l'essentiel des voix au cœur
de ceux qui ont fait la candidature
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017
s'élève parmi la majorité je leur dis en
dépit de tous ce qui nous sépare en
dépit de notre opposition résolue mon
respect mon admiration pour leur courage
pour leur sens de l'honneur dans un
moment où les votes que nous allons
faire ne déterminent pas Surel B nous
nous asseyons ne détermine pas si nous
sommes de gauche ou de droite détermine
si nous savons préserver les valeurs de
la République son histoire son identité
et finalement l'âme de notre nation
puisse-elle ses voix en appeler d'autres
mes chers collègues nous avons toujours
le choix vous aviez le choix de retirer
ce texte après la motion de rejet et de
ne pas faire entrer par la fenêtre d'une
commission mixte paritaire un texte
rejeté souverainement par la porte de
l'Assemblée nationale
vous aviez le choix voyant le dérapage
face auquel vous étiez les
compromissions qui vous étaient demandé
par la droite radicalisé de renoncer à
faire examiner ce texte des voix se sont
élevé jusqu'au sein du gouvernement pour
que ce texte ne soit pas soumis au vote
ce soir il est encore temps collègues
d'arrêter cette farce grotesque qui vire
au drame il est temps collègues de nous
souvenir des raisons pour lesquelles
nous sommes ici de l'histoire don nous
sommes les dépositaires et des valeurs
qui nous appartient de défendre nous
devons empêcher aujourd'hui
l'effondrement de la République et au
final de la démocratie l'engloutissement
sous les thèmes et les termes mis dans
le débat public tel un poison par la
famille Le Pen collègues
réveillons-nous je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Elsa
faossillon pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et
républicaine
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues c'est
l'histoire d'un gouvernement qui n'avait
pas de majorité pas de cap pas de
colonne
vertébrale l'histoire d'une chef de
gouvernement qui voulait sauver son
poste coûte que coûte quoi qu'il en
coûte à des millions d'étrangers qui
fuit la guerre la fin et le dglement
climatique au péril de leur vie chers
collègues c'est l'histoire d'un
président qui s'est fait élire contre
l'extrême droite et qui nous propose
aujourd'hui de voter son
programme sans majorité vous voilà
aujourd'hui entraîné dans ce que
l'extrême droite a toujours rêvé de
faire l'alliance des droites et de
l'extrême droite depuis plusieurs jours
les pires tractations politiciennes ont
lieu dans l'h clos de Matignon et de
l'Élysée au mépris de la séparation des
pouvoirs la CMP est instrumentalisée
pour contourner le Parlement et conclure
coûte que coûte avec la droite LR aligné
sur les positions du rassemblement
national rendez-vous compte collègues Le
Pen fille valide cette loi regardez les
députés du rassemblement national tout
sourire avec la hargne et l'envie d'en
découdre celle des presque gagnants les
théories de l'appel d'air et du Grand
remplacement légitimé au gré des
articles la préférence nationale gravée
dans la loi ils peuvent ils peuvent
l'esprit tranquille faire mine de
s'attaquer au sujet du pouvoir d'achat
des Français eux les boul
poujadistes au petit pied qui refusent
d'augmenter le
SMIC le seul appel d'air que je ressens
il a une odeur nausée abonde c'est celui
du racisme et de la xénophobie
décomplexé que vos manœuvres favorisent
quelle déchéance quelle faute historique
de dresser ainsi un plateau d'argent à
l'extrême droite à l'heure de la fièvre
populiste et du fascisme qui gangrinene
nos démocraties car la faute ne prend
pas racine dans la CMP mais dès la
proposition du texte là où l'extrême
droite arrive au pouvoir par les urnes
elle y accède d'abord à cause des grands
renoncements des abandons des
compromissions de ceux qui sont au
pouvoir avant
elle la contrefaçon raciste n'est jamais
préféré à l'original l'histoire nous
regarde chers collègues n'ajoutez pas le
déshonneur à la compromission rejetez ce
texte de la honte
oui la honte la honte pour un président
de la République élu pour faire barrage
à l'extrême droite la honte pour notre
pays et ses valeurs de voir ici un texte
qui s'apparente à un trac du Front
national avec les mots de Jean-Marie Le
Pen dans le texte certains articles
reprennent les mêmes formules et les
mêmes propositions défendues depuis des
décennies par le Front national
préférence nationale quota caution de
retour pour les étudiants étrangers
atteinte au droit du sol déchéance de
nationalité prendez-vous compte
collègues ces mesures ne sont même pas
mises en place par le gouvernement de
Georgia Moni t cité par Monsieur le
Ministre
d'Anin les tractations et les
marchandages à l'œuvre depuis quelques
jours sont l'apanage de ceux qui ne
gouverneent plus pour le peuple mais
sans le peuple piètres tacticien que
vous êtes qui n'ont que faire des
centaines de milliers d'humains qu'ils
abandonnent et qu'il vilipandent il n'y
a pas de France comme le prétendent les
promoteurs du choc des civilisations
mais bien un peuple en quête d'unité
autour de l'égalité et les lits
d'hôpitaux supprimés les prof non
remplacé les bureaux de les bureaux de
poste qui ferment les déserts médicaux
sont le fruit de choix politique de vos
choix politiques et non de celui d'un
solde migratoire stable dans notre pays
à celles et ceux qui s'étranglent devant
cette rédition ne sauvez pas que votre
honneur refusez laabî nos désaccords
nombreux persisteront mais cette
dernière digue ce dernier rempart face à
une idéologie mortifère qui fait de
l'étranger la 5è colonne devrait nous
conduire au même vote
l'histoire enseigne qu'avant de rejeter
l'autre de lui fermer la porte son
humanité lui a été déignée c'est de fait
la menace à laquelle nous faisons
face regardez regardez donc où la folie
raciste mène les dispositions ajouté en
CMP vont renforcer la misère et la
précarité parce que vous n'avez pas de
réponse politique à proposer au désordre
du monde à commencé par la crise sociale
que nous traversons c'est la politique
du bouc émissaire l'étranger et le
pauvre comme et demi il existe des
droits inaliénables lorsqu'on accepte de
les daigner à certains alors ils sont
fragilisés pour
tous cette folie raciste vous conduit
même à couper les allocations familiales
ou la prime de rentrée scolaire à des
enfants français au prétexte qu'ils ont
des des parents étrangers tout cela est
une folie refusezla mes chers collègues
je vous le dis solennellement vous allez
écrire ce soir une page de notre
histoire l'histoire un pays qui en ce 19
décembre pourrait renoncer à ses valeurs
ses valeurs humanistes et basculer faire
vers le pire ne faites pas
ça je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe neelen pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre ma et
[Applaudissements]
territoire merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
mes chers collègues c'est un texte
important que sur laquel nous devons
nous positionner ce soir dans notre
groupe nous partons du principe qu'aucun
sujet aucun sujet ne doit être mis sous
le tapis nous voulions un débat un débat
qui était censé durer de semaines sur
lequel chacun d'entre nous aurait pu
exprimer ses positions
malheureusement malheureusement nous ne
l'avons pas eu sur un sujet aussi
important sur lequel nos concitoyens se
sentent aussi concernés il est dommage
d'avoir résumé le débat à 2 jours de CMP
au lieu de 2 semaines de travail ici
dans cette hémicycle mais sur un sujet
aussi important nous ne faisons preuve
d'aucun angélisme mais d'cun jusqu'au
bouhisme 74 % des Français disent qu'ils
veulent
moins d'immigration alors qu'en même
temps 62 % disent qu'ils sont favorables
à la régularisation des travailleurs au
cas par cas nous entendons et nous
comprenons ces deux points de vue nous
souhaitons de l'équilibre nous
souhaitons protéger nos compatriotes
mais en même temps nous souhaitons
intégrer les étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui travaille et qui crée de
la
valeur lorsque l'on est en situation
irrégulière qu'on ne respecte pas le
droit
républicain lorsqu'on ne respecte pas
l'ordre public on n pas sa place sur le
territoire français mais lorsqu'on
travaille en France qu'on crée de la
valeur qu'on paye des impôts on a le
droit à un statut lorsque l'on veut
vivre dans un pays il est important d'en
connaître la langue pour en faciliter
l'intégration mais lorsqu'une entreprise
veut employer un étranger en situation
irrégulière il est normal qu'elle
participe au financement de son
apprentissage pour encore une fois
apprendre la langue et s'intégrer
lorsqu'un étranger entre et entré en
état de manière irrégulière sur les
territoires l'ancien article 621 du cza
il est important pour nous de le
rétablir car c'est une demande de nos
forces de police de nos forces de
sécurité pour un meilleur suivi des
étrangers présents sur notre territoire
mais lorsqu'un employeur exploite un
étranger en situation irrégulière il est
légitime qu'il soit sanctionné en
réalité par ces six exemples c'était
l'esprit que nous recherchion dans ce
texte un esprit d'équilibre encore une
fois ne pas écouter tout ce qui est
excessif et qu'on a pu entendre pendant
une partie des débats mais simplement
faire preuve d'un certain réalisme d'un
certain pragmatisme par rapport à la
situation actuelle ne pas résumer ce
texte c'est sur quelques titres
médiatiques tel qu'on a pu le voir mais
prendre en compte les 86 articles qui le
composent se rendre compte que en effet
le diable est parfois dans les détails
et c'est ces détails là qui font que ce
texte permettra demain de combler des
trous qui sont présents dans notre
aququette du droit français je voudrais
aussi en profiter pour parler du titre 6
extrêmement important pour notre pour
notre groupe mes cinq collègues
ultramarin Olivier serva max mathazan
Estelle yousoufa Nathalie Bassir
Stéphane Lenormand se sont énormément
investis pour que le titre 6 qui parle
des outremèes que nos outremèes soient
respectés dans ce texte contrairement à
la version initiale cette version du
Sénat où en fin de compte tout était
relayé avec des circulaires et c'est
grâce au travail du rapporteur serva qui
a fait énormément d'auditions sur le
sujet que nous avons à texte qui rend
hommage et qui respecte nos territoires
ultramarin de la hauteur d'esprit du
pragmatisme c'est ce qui a guidé nos
choix pendant l'étude de ce texte notre
groupe fort de ses horizons diverses
vous inquiétez pas monsieur Pradier on
va y arriver vous savez c'est un peu
comme vous on a toujours entendu jusqu'à
la dernière minute pour savoir où vous
positionnez on fait un petit peu pareil
notre groupe fort de ses horizons
diverses et reste partager sur ce texte
certains d'entre vous en effet d'entre
nous ont décidé d'apporter sa voix à ce
texte quand d'autres ont décidé plutôt
de s'y opposer ou de s'y abstenir mais
la réalité et le point qu'il faut
retenir c'est qu'on regrette surtout que
ce débat a été écourté au détriment de
l'expression
parlementaire je vous
remercie monsieur le député la parole
est à monsieur le Président Maillard
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Renaissance madame la
Présidente messieurs les ministres
monsieur le rapporteur général chers
collègues lorsque le projet de loi pour
contrôler l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration a été déposé au Parlement
son ambition était déjà claire et
radicale agir efficacement et rapidement
pour redonner toute sa cohérence à notre
système
migratoire mais malgré l'importance de
l'enjeu une coalition contre nature a
choisi d'empêcher le débat dans cet
hémicycle un débat qui aurait permis de
parler de l'ensemble des sujets devant
l'ensemble des Français
chacun vivra avec ses remords et ses
regrets
désormais le texte qui est devant nous
et celui issu de la commission mixte
paritaire sur ce texte mon groupe a
d'emblé désigné collectivement ces
lignes rouges et je consta que celles-ci
ont été respectées premièrement sur la
création d'un dispositif de
régularisation pour les travailleurs
étrangers dans le secteur en tenstion il
est heureux que la justesse de T
dispositions a été reconnue je le redis
ici comme je l'ai toujours fait nos
entreprises nos serv publics ont besoin
de travailleurs étrangers prêts à s'y
engager l'interdiction de tout mineur
dans les centres de rétention
administrative était également un point
sur lequel nous n'avons jamais voulu
transiger de même l'éborgement d'urgence
est un droit qui ne saurait être remise
en cause
sans aller à l'encontre de la tradition
d'accueil et la solidarité de la France
il continuera à s'appliquer envers tous
ceux qui sont dans le
besoin bien entendu on ne sort jamais
d'une négociation pleinement satisfait
et je regrette que le texte final
comporte encore un trop grand nombre de
dispositions susceptibles d'être censuré
par le juge constitutionnel elles ne
sont pas de notre fait mais je constate
que 26 des 27 articles originaux de ce
projet de loi ont été conservés c'est
donc que les Français nous donnent
raison lorsqu'il plébiscite à plus de 70
% ses
mesures aussi ce
texte remplira deux impératifs que mon
groupe lui avait assigné dès le début
celui de la fermeté lorsque c'est
nécessaire celui de l'intégration
lorsque c'est mérité un objectif de
fermeté d'abord avec la simplification
des voies de recours qui passent de 12 à
3 afin que ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à
rester dans notre pays sen ail dans les
plus brefs délais rappelons-le avec ce
projet de loi ce sont 4000 étrangers
deslinquant que nous pourrons expulser
immédiatement un objectif d'intégration
ensuite par l'apprentissage de la langue
et l'exigence d'un niveau minimal mais
aussi et nous y tenons par l'accès au
car la vérité est là même si certains
par naïveté ou démagogie politicienne
refuse obstinément de
l'admettre la France a besoin des
dispositions de ce projet de
loi les Français n'en peuvent plus des
fausses promesses et des
demi-mesures les Français ne nous
demande pas des symboles il nous demande
de
l'efficacité quand je regarde à
l'extrême gauche je vois ceux qui ont
été élus en faisant l'électoralisme sur
les
étrangers quand je regarde à l'extrême
droite je vois ceux qui ont été élus sur
du populisme contre les
immigrés Madame Le Pen nous ne voulons
pas votre vote cynique et opportuniste
et nous n voudrons
jamais car
aujourd'hui l JEE notre
hémicycle qui sont les seuls
responsables qui sont les seuls qui
étaient prêts à débattre et voter un
texte équilibré nous et donc en accord
avec la responsabilité qui s'impose à
tout parti qui se dit de gouvernement
nous voterons ce projet de loi je vous
remercie monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Président la parole est à Monsieur
Johann Gillet pour le rassemblement
national
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues on attaque que ce qui compte
avez-vous dit à cette tribune il y a
quelques instants monsieur le ministre
alors chers collègu chère marine étant
donné le nombre de propos désobligeants
à notre égard il est clair que nous
comptons monsieur le
ministre vous avez un bilan en matière
d'immigration un triste bilan 1,6
million de titres de séjour délivrés à
des immigrés extrauropéens rien qu'en
2022 entre 700 et 900000 étrangers
clandestins sur le territoire national
400000 bénéficiaires de laame en 2022
pour un coût d'un milliard eur des
demandes d'asile triplé en 10 ans des
otf très peu exécuté vous êtes
d'ailleurs sans doute l'un des plus
mauvais ministres en la matière des
victimes des victimes par centaines dû à
une immigration
déraisonnée aujourd'hui vous le savez 80
% des Français souhaitent des mesures
fermes en matière d'immigration les
députés que nous sommes ne peuvent
l'ignorer évidemment nos concitoyens
savent qu'ils peuvent compter sur le
rassemblement national sur ce sujet
comme sur bien d'autres car nous avons
été précurseurs et nous avons alerté et
proposer des solutions il y a bien
longtemps déjà chers
collègues je le crois sincèrement nos
idées sont majoritaires dans ce
pays
initialement insuffisant et même
immigrationniste ce projet de loi a
considérablement évolué avec le soutien
des Fran français nous avons fait plier
le gouvernement si ce texte est loin
d'être parfait nous avons
imposé nous avons imposé des avancées
majeures instauration d'une priorité
nationale pour les prestations
sociales rétablissement du délit de
séjours irrégulierers
déchéanch d'échéan de nationalité pour
les binationaux qui s'en prennent
notamment à nos forces de l'ordre et
dururcissement du regroupement familial
et de l'octroi des titres de séjour
autant de mesures que nous portons
depuis des années et qui sont largement
plébisités par les Français et qui se
retrouvent ce soir dans ce texte de loi
cette victoire idéologique cette
reconnaissance de nos solutions prouve
s'il le fallait que la politique que
vous avez mené jusqu'à présent celle du
en même temps ne fonctionne pas au
rassemblement nation nous sommes restés
sur une ligne claire quand le texte
initial du gouvernement prévoyait tout
un attirail de mesures néfastes et
allant dans le sens d'un renforcement de
l'immigration nous nous Ress toujours
orientés vers le seul intérêt général
nous avons convaincu les Français
d'abord mais nous avons visiblement
convaincu ici aussi dans les bancs de
tous les groupes de l'arc républicain
expurger du droit automatique à la
ce texte contient désormais des avancées
dans la lutte contre l'immigration
toutefois le durcissement de ces mesures
que nous avons obtenu ne doit pas
occulter les angles morts qui restent
encore
nombreux ce texte reste en effet muet
sur la suppression de la me la trop
grande facilité à obtenir la nationalité
française le problème criant des
prétendus mineurs étrangers le
dévoiement du droit d'asile et
évidemment le contrôle de nos frontières
vous semblez ignorer les problèmes de
notre pays c'est faill pour notre
sécurité collective pour les comptes
publics pour la démraie pour la
démographie pardon et pour
l'économie mais parce que nous sommes
des députés responsables nous allons
voter pour cette loi permettant
d'améliorer la situation mais mais nous
ne mentons pas au français nous l'avons
dit cette loi est insuffisante mais elle
est le petit acte 1 le grand acte 2
celui qui pourra résoudre en profondeur
les problèmes de l'immigration passera
inévitablement par un référendum ce
référendum ce référendum que Marine Le
Pen demande depuis tant d'années sera au
cœur de ce deuxè acte les Français le
savent s'ils font confiance à Marine Le
Pen en 2027 ils retrouveront le pouvoir
ils auront entre leur main les solutions
démocratiques pour répondre à l'ENSEM de
leurs
aspirationstire
sur de nombre autres sujets je vous
remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Elisa
Martin pour la France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise
merci
est merci madame la
Présidente de petit compromis en petit
compromis on ne sait jamais quand on
arrive au pire disait Simone
veille suppression déguisée de l'aide
médicale
d'État restriction drastique du
regroupement
familial condition d'accès absurde au
titre de séjours étranger malad
préférence nationale pour l'accès aux
prestations sociales évincement des
étudiants noneopéens de nos universités
fin du droit du sol déchéance de
nationalité fin de l'indépendance de
l'Office français de protection des
réfugiés et des
apatrides fin de la représentation du
Haut commissariat des réfugiés dans la
procédure d'asile généralisation du juge
unique à la Cour nationale du droit
d'asile atteinte au droit au procès
équitable et au garanties procédural des
demandeurs
d'asile interdiction d'accès à un
hébergement d'urgence enfermement
facilité délivrance automatique des
obligations de quitter le territoire
multiplication des expulsions des
personnes vers des pays où elles sont
gravement menacées maintien du placement
des enfants dans le centre de rétention
de maotte le texte c'est l'annonce d'une
catastrophe sociale et sanitaire la
promotion du racisme et du rejet de
l'autre l'introduction de la préférence
nationale l'inscription dans la loi du
programme de Jean-Marie Le
Pen ce projet de loi est un échec dans
une démocratie votre votre projet rejeté
aurait été retiré et le ministre de
l'Intérieur
démissionn comment
osez-vous nous dire que nous voulons
éviter le débat vous qui en êtes avec
votre 23e
493 comment osez-vous dire que nous
avons voté avec le rassemblement
national vous qui en reprenez
l'idéologie et le programme comment
osez-vous dire que le durcissement du
texte et de notre responsabilité alors
que dès le départ vous le saviez destiné
à une commission mixte paritaire dominée
par la droite extrême cette commission
mixte paritaire est un échec vous le
gouvernement avez court-circuité cette
CMP par des par des tractations de
couloirs hier soir le Sénat a déménagé à
Matignon l'Élysée s'est invité au Palais
Bourbon mais la séparation des pouvoirel
a été définitivement piétiné vos graves
compromis la France des droits humains
et on ne s'en relèvera pas de siôt
monsieur le Président de la République
madame la Première ministre vous avez
troqué votre peu d'humanité au profit de
vos minables carrières vous avez troqué
vos Coles blancs au profit des chemises
brunes votre législature est un échec
vous les députés aujourd'hui le
programme sur lequel vous avez été élu
est mort
choisissez-vous de faire des plus
vulnérables de nouveaux pauvres
choisissez-vous de vous aligner sur les
conditions posées par le Front national
il n'y a pas de mandat impératif en
République comme parlementaire nous
sommes libre et ce soir vous avez un
choix la collaboration ou la
République ne perdons pas de vue
l'essentiel des milliers de personnes
craignent pour leur sort des millions
nous scrutent en direct
liard notre France prête à sombrer
défaudons nos tradition républicain sans
compromis ni compromission liberté
égalité fraternité le Tex le fascisme en
marche vive la République vive la France
retirez votre
texte je vous remercie la parole est à
présés
pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains madame la Présidente
messieurs les
ministres la semaine dernière dans une
improbable alliance laanupè et l'aelle
gauche de votre majorité adopt en
commission des lois un texte contraire
aux attentes des Français parce qu'il
prévoyait des régularisations massives
parce qu'il encourageait la demande
d'asile comme filière d'immigration
clandestine ce n'était évidemment pas à
la hauteur de ce sursaut que demande le
pays nous l'avons donc
rejeté aujourd'hui la CMP s'est accordé
sur un autre texte pour l'essentiel
celui des républicains tel que l'avait
adopté la majorité sénatoriale
que ce matin encore le remblement
National le rejet ce texte il vous donne
les moyens d'avoir enfin une vraie
politique migratoire avec des cotas
migratoires opposabl ce ne seront plus
les passeurs qui diront qui nous devons
accueillir mais ce sera le Parlement
français en accrant mieux l'accueil des
étudiants étrangers pour lutter contre
les abus
urcissant les conditions du regroupement
familial en faisant en sorte que notre
modèle social ne soit plus ce mirage
d'un a Dorado ouvert et offert à tous
les vents en rétablissant le séjour le
délit de séjour
irrégulier indispensable étant attendu
partout en France et en particulier à
maotte chermsour
camardine et
puis trois mesures importantes sur la
nationalité
exprime cette idée simple que la France
comme toutes les nations doit apprendre
à se faire respecter à faire respecter
son autorité la déchéance de nationalité
pour les binationaux coupables d'omicide
sur un policier ou un
gendarme la fin du droit du sol
automatique à la majorité pour les
enfants nés en France de parents
étrangers ils devront en manifester la
volonté entre le 16 ans et leur 18 ans
parce qu'on ne devient pas français par
hasard on ne devient pas français sans
le vouloir et
enfin la restriction du droit du sol
pour en exclure les délinquants
condamnés à une peine de 10 ans de
prison ce texte marque un véritable
tournant pour la première fois depuis
longtemps la France se donne les moyens
de reprendre le contrôle de sa politique
migratoire il est animé par un principe
simple moins d'immigration et plus
d'expulsion des étrangers
indésirables l'enjeu il en vaut la peine
et devrait tous nous rassembler puisque
c'est l'avenir de notre cohésion
nationale restera maintenant à votre
gouvernement à appliquer la loi dans
toute sa
rigueur ce texte marque un tournant mais
ne nous racontons pas d'histoire ne
racontons pas d'histoire français tout
cela ne suffira pas la portée de cette
loi demeurera limitée parce que les
nombreux verrous juridictionnels qui
organisent notre impuissance subsiste
j'ai évidemment à l'esprit cette
jurisprudence des juges français et
européens qui se livre à une surenchère
d'interprétation toujours plus extensive
de principes qui ont pour unique point
commun de passer outre les règles votées
par les les représentants du peuple
français si nous voulons retrouver
pleinement notre souveraineté en matière
migratoire si nous ne voulons plus vivre
un épisode
humiliant comme ce moment où le Conseil
d'État exige du ministre de l'Intérieur
qu'il organise le rapatriment d'un bec
radicalisé et dangereux alors je vous le
dis avec les républicains je vous le
répète nous devons réviser notre
Constitution
en ce moment décisif je voudrais
partager avec tous ceux parmi vous qui
crient leur attachement à la démocratie
les mots de Philippe segin à cette même
tribune il y a 30 ans rien n'est plus
dangereux qu'une nation trop longtemps
frustrée de la souveraineté par laquelle
s'exprime sa liberté c'est-à-dire son
droit imprescriptible à choisir son
destin puisse puiss cette
réflexionpir président de la République
s'il veut redonner aux Français
confiance et espoir dans leur démocratie
et dans l'avenir de notre
nation je vous remercie monsieur le
Président avant de donner la parole aux
deux
orateurs inscrits je vous rappelle que
la Conférence des Présidents a décidé
qu'il serait procédé à un scrutin public
sur le projet de loi tel qu'il résulte
du texte de la commission mixte
paritaire je fais a déjà annoncé le
scrutin dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale la parole est à monsieur le
Président matthi pour le groupe
démocrate merci
Madame merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues voilà près d'un an que
les discussions se sont engagées sur ce
texte certains diront à juste titre les
autres non peu importe le texte est là
et nous sommes face à nos
responsabilités l'origine le groupe
démocrate a considéré que le projet du
gouvernement était bleub bon équilibré
intégrateur et ferme pour tous ceux qui
ont vocation à rester chez nous clair et
juste pour ceux qui doivent quitter
notre sol il ne restait qu'au Parlement
à faire son œuvre de législateur
malheureusement lundi dernier une
majorité d'élus du peuple a renié sa
parole donnée à ceux qui les ont élus en
votant la motion de rejet venant de la
gauche rallant à eux les voix de la
droite et de l'extrême droite c'est une
première dans l'histoire de cette
assemblée qui s'est muselé
volontairement
sachez-le ceux qui l'ont voté devront
rendre des comptes à leur électeur pour
notre part évidemment nous voulions
discuter quel que soit le résultat du
moment que cela Procé d'un débat
démocratique il n a rien été et chacun
d'entre nous groupe démocrate le
regrette profondément de quoi
parlons-nous ici ce soir de l'identité
de la France de son histoire de sa place
dans le monde nous parlons aussi des
Français et de ce qu'ils attendre pour
le groupe modem l'identité de la France
c'est l'image d'une terre d'accueil par
son histoire sa place dans le monde
c'est celle du rayonnement de son savoir
de sa culture de sa langue et les
Français que veulent-ils au groupe
démocrate nous sommes convaincus qu'ils
attendent de nous de la fermeté du bon
sens et de l'humanité ils attendent que
les règles soient respectées quand une
octf est délivrée elle doit être mise en
œuvre dans les meilleurs délais quand un
étranger arrive il doit apprendre notre
langue et quand un émigré travaille paye
des impôts des cotisations sociales
alors il doit il a le droit d'avoir une
carte de séjour parce que nous avons
besoin de lui et s'il travaille et bien
il doit aussi toucher des prestations
qui sont la base de notre contrat social
à l'égal de tous les autres
cotisants parce que si nous les sortons
nous-même de notre contrat social et
républicain si nous décidons des le
départ de notre communauté comment
peut-on leur demander de s'intégrer dans
notre société mes chers collègues nous
trompons pas les migrations ne sont pas
prêtes de s'arrêter elles vont même
s'accélérer c'est d'ailleurs l'histoire
du
t que nous la connaissons depuis
toujours pour
conclure je veux saluer le travail du
ministre de l'Intérieur et de la
première ministre tout au long de ces
mois pour bâtir avec patience et respect
le texte nous est soumis ce soir je veux
saluer aussi la détermination de no
gouvernement à ne pas accepter une
majorité qui ne respecterit pas nos
valeurs et j'invite mes collègues
députés à prendre en compte cette marque
de profond respect de ce que nous sommes
ce texte n'est pas parfait nous le
savons mais il est le fruit de compromis
démocratique que nous voulons assumer
pleinement parce que au groupe démocrate
nous respectons chacun parce que les
deux mots qui nous guident depuis
toujours conscience et
responsabilité les députés du groupe
démocrate que j'ai l'honneur de présider
sont libres de leur votes je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
président
et pour
terminer la parole est à monsieur le
Président VO pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
socialiste madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre député de la majorité c'est
à vous que je so souhaite avant tout
m'adresser je sais qu'il est parmi vous
des humanistes sincères des hommes et
des femmes qui ne transigent pas avec
les principes et se tiennent du côté de
les lumières je les salue souvenez-vous
de
2017 de 2022 les conditions de
l'élection du président Macron face à
l'extrême droite ne voix se mélant au
vôre parce qu'il en allait de
l'essentiel à celles et à ceux qui ont
voté pour moi non pour soutenir mes
idées mais pour faire barrage à celle de
l'extrême droite votre vote m'oblige
disait-il alors demandez-vous maintenant
où nous en sommes à cette heure où le
crépuscule de la nuit se confond avec le
crépuscule de la raison dans laquelle
nous plonge votre loi alors que tout ce
que vous aviez tenu pour des lignes
rouges a été allègrement transgressé et
que vous vous rapprochez franchissez
désormais des lignes bleu marines rien
n'obligez le gouvernement qui a tout
négocié à tout céder rien ne vous oblige
à céder à une droite devenu le valet
docile de l'extrême droite rien ne vous
oblige à vous aventurer sur des terres
qui ne sont pas les vôtres et que
d'autres après vous utiliserai contre la
République contre l'État de droit et en
définitive contre la France où en
sommes-nous ce soir mes chers collègues
l'utorant de haine de l'extrême droite
c'est grossi de la démagogie et des
mensonges de la droite avec la
complexité de l'exécut
n n'avons pas débattu de Politi
migratoire mais de Politi
antiimmigré ce débat méritait pourtant
mieux que cette coalition funeste de
l'ignorance des préjugés et de
l'opportunisme mes chers collègues de la
majorité ce projet ne tiendra qu'une
promesse le malheur de tous où en
sommes-nous la question n'est pas
seulement de savoir avec qui vous allez
voter mais
plusement vous allez voter une politique
de côtin migratoire débattu au Parlement
comme le voulait François Fillon la
préférence nationale victoire de
Jean-Marie Le Pen pour l'accès à de
nombreuses prestations sociales aussis
essentiel que les allocations familiales
où en sommes-nous ce soir indurcissement
des conditions du regroupement familial
un rétrécissement du titre étranger
malade des étudiants étrangers dissuadés
de venir par le paiement d'une caution
une atteinte au droit du sol une
régression des régularisation par le
travail le retour de la double peine de
la déchéance
dealité le rétablissement du délit de
séjour irrégulier le renforcement des
conditions de l'aide au développement la
remise en cause de l'inconditionnalité
de l'accueil la réduction des droits des
déboutés du droit d'asile et comme si ce
ne suffisait pas demain la promesse
d'une révision
deame qu'est-ce que cette loi mes chers
collègues une mauvaise loi de police des
étrangers c'est le programme du
rassemblement national la nausée et les
mains
sales nous le cessons ici sur tous les
bans d'entendre parler d'ordre mais de
quel ordre parle-t-on celui de Monsieur
Orban celui de Madame mélony celui de
Madame Le Pen il y a l'ordre qui cache
le désordre et qui s'oppose à la justice
quel ordre mes chers collègues l'ordre
sanglant qui laisse mourir Méditerrané
où l'homme se perd lui-même l'ordre qui
prend ses pouvoirs dans la haine la
République sign'ignore assurément mes
chers collègues cet ordre n'est pas le
nôtre cet ordre n'est pas l'ordre de
républicain et ce n'est pas l'ordre qui
renforce la justice c'est la justice qui
donne sa certitude à l'ordre voilà avec
Camu quel est notre façon de concevoir
la chose ce texte enfin est un grand
mensonge fait français et aux Français
il ne règlera rien va-t-il permettre de
contrôler l'immigration il y aura-t-il
moins d'hommes et de femmes qui tend
leur pays pour fuir la misère moins de
passeurs moins de noyés moins de
migrants arrivés sur nos côtes qui peut
le croire y aura-t-il moins de gens dans
les tentes moins de files d'attente
devant les préfectures moins de
contentieux dans les tribunaux
administratifs plus de laisser passer
consulaires et de reconduite non moins
de travailleurs sans papier non mes
chers collègues nous en sommes là vous
pouvez laisser à d'autres cette défaite
morale laissez-la au ministre de
l'Intérieur laissez-la à la première
ministre et à leur lâche soulagement
mesdames et messieurs de la majorité ce
texte est celui d'un gouvernement
agissant sous la dicté de la droite et
de de l'extrême droite rien ne vous
oblige à les suivre dans le déshonneur
il y a dans cet hémicycle une majorité
pour ajouter de la peur à la peur de
l'indignité à l'indignité du malheur au
malheur l'histoire vous regarde il ESTs
de repousser ce texte et de voter contre
vive la république et vive la
France je vous
remercie la discussion en général est
close je vous précise que certains
parlementaires ont avaient l'intention
de brandir des affiches j'ai demandé aux
huissiers de venir vous les retirer je
vous indique que c'est contraire à notre
règlement et et que le bureau a déjà
sanctionné un certain nombre d'entre
vous pour des faits similaires donc vous
savez très bien que c'est contraire à
l'article
9 de l'instruction générale du
[Applaudissements]
bureau alors je
vais je vais mettre au voie le projet de
loi tel qu'il est issu de la commission
mixte paritaire je vous demande de bien
vouloir regagner vos places scrutin est
[Applaudissements]
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
573 exprimé 535 majorité 268 pour 349
contre 186 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté et la séance est suspendue